what's going on everybody it's Warren
and we are now only one day away from
Avengers in game being one month away we
are one month away for going to see it
the day before which I think a lot of
people are and with it coming so soon
I've talked about a few of the
characters changes in upgrades such as
Tony Stark's new Iron Man armor possibly
the mark 85 that everybody is talking
about The Hulk and Bruce Banner turning
into professor Hulk and in this video I
want to talk about Captain America
getting his new shield from Tony Stark
and Avengers in game which i think is
something that people tend to forget was
mentioned I'll talk about that and break
it all down in this video but real quick
if you're new to my channel be sure to
subscribe
I do monthly giveaways right now I'm
giving away 5 imax tickets so you and
some friends can go see Avengers and
Gaiman hi max all you have to do to
enter for your chance to win is be a
subscriber like the video and comment
down below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero or villain so as I
said something that I think people tend
to forget is that Tony Stark has built a
new prototype shield for Captain America
we know this because it is mentioned in
spider-man homecoming happy Hogan is
loading up all the things from stark
tower and moving them to the new
facility in upstate New York and when
he's on the phone he says that he's
almost done and he says we just got a
load up Tony's old Hulk Buster armor a
prototype for captain's new shield and
Thor's magic belt so it's evident that
Tony has been working on a new shield
for Captain America the last time we saw
Captain America with his shield is when
he dropped it and left it with Tony at
the end of Captain America Civil War and
since that moment he's never gotten it
back because he's never ran into Tony
again which is why he fought with the
shields that T'Challa gave him an
infinity war but now thanks to the
Avengers end game trailers we know that
Captain America will end up back at the
Avengers HQ in upstate New York which is
where the shield is and we know that
Tony Stark will also be back at the
Avengers headquarters with Captain
America thanks again to the trailers so
Captain America is going to get his
shield back in Avengers end game and
again we know this because we see him
with it in the trailers we see it in the
one scene which looks like a battle and
where he looks really beat up and if you
look closely in the second trailer in
the Instagram video because it's a
different aspect ratio you can see that
Captain America is holding a shield as
he's walking in his quantum realm suit
so it's very evident that he will get
shield back from Tony but what upgrades
has Tony made to it and is it the same
shield with some upgrades to it or is it
a completely different shield altogether
because since nanotech is Tony Stark's
peak of all his technology he could have
made a shield for Captain America using
nanotech
however vibranium can't really be
destroyed so unless he figured out a way
to melt it down and cover the nanobots
with it a nanotech shield would probably
be a completely different shield and
we've actually got a recent toy leak
with Captain America holding a new
shield as you can see it definitely
looks like it's been upgraded and it
even has a weapon on it this is
definitely from Stark and it seems like
it's nanotechnology it serves as the
same basic shield that Captain America
is used to using but can turn into
different weapons much like Tony Stark's
mark 50 nanotechnology suit so it's
looking like Captain America's new
shield will be made out of nanotech and
maybe it could even have some of the
elements of Captain America's energy
shield from the comics however if
Captain America gets a new shield
altogether I definitely think that he'll
wield that one and his old one in
Avengers endgame perhaps he willed the
new one at first but when they go to
fight Thanos again in the beginning of
the movie
Thanos destroys it and then he goes back
to wielding his old one whatever the
case may be we will see Captain America
wielding a new upgraded shield and
Avengers end game so let me know your
thoughts on this do you think Tony
upgraded Captain America's old shield or
do you think it's a new shield
altogether and do you think it's going
to be made out of nanotechnology let me
know your thoughts in the comments down
below and again don't forget to
subscribe comment and like the video so
you can enter the giveaway and stay up
to date on everything relating to
Avengers endgame and Marvel as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof
[Music]